Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Welcome to The Rest Is History, and we kick off today's episode, the final episode of our London Week, with very, very sad news, Tom.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、提前解锁系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、提前解锁、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistory.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是苹果播客应用，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。欢迎来到《历史的余烬》，我们今天迎来了伦敦周的最后关头，这一集的开场，我们要播报一个非常、非常悲伤的消息，汤姆。
Yeah. We've been sitting by the phone, haven't we? Two episodes ago, we ended on a cliffhanger. Well, we needed to discover netflix or some other streaming giant would take us up on our um suggestion of a tv series a best-selling blockbuster tv series um based on the life of henry fielding and his brother john and the bow street runners um with future possible spin-offs involving dr johnson hunting ghosts. I regret to say, Tom. They have stared a gift horse in the mouth.
是的。我们一直在守着电话，不是吗？两集之前，我们在一个悬念中结束。嗯，我们需要看看网飞或其他流媒体巨头是否会采纳我们关于电视剧的建议，一部畅销的大片电视剧，呃，以亨利·菲尔丁和他的兄弟约翰以及保罗街巡警的故事为基础，呃，未来甚至可能衍生出约翰逊博士猎鬼的故事。我很遗憾地通知你，汤姆。他们真是暴殄天物。
Yeah. They've foolishly thrown away the chance. So we'll be offering it to Amazon starting from now. In the meantime, we are sticking with the podcasting lark. So that's good news for some, bad news for people who don't know the podcast, but why would they be listening? So we are going to finish off our London week.
是的。他们愚蠢地错失了这个机会。所以从现在开始，我们要把它推荐给亚马逊。与此同时，我们还是要坚持播客这门老行当。这对某些人来说是个好消息，对那些不了解这个播客的人来说是个坏消息——不过他们为什么会听呢？所以我们要为伦敦周画上句号。
We've done the walk around Smithfield with the ill-fitting shoes. We did London people. We had CLR James and Henry Fielding. We had London places. We had the Two Eyes coffee bar, and we had Barking Abbey. And if you've been with us since the start of the week, you'll remember that we did our walk around Roman London, and we're going to end by each choosing a London moment, a kind of a cultural moment or political moment. It could be anything. So I've got mine. And Tom, I think you're going to go first, aren't you?
我们穿着不合脚的鞋子在史密斯菲尔德漫步。我们聊了伦敦人。我们讲了CLR·詹姆斯和亨利·菲尔丁。我们聊了伦敦的地标。我们去了“双眼”咖啡吧，还有巴金修道院。如果你从本周一开始就一直关注我们，你就会记得我们曾漫步古罗马伦敦，而最后，我们将各自挑选一个伦敦的高光时刻——某种文化时刻或政治时刻。什么都可以。我选好了。汤姆，我想你先来，对吧？
Yeah, because mine is chronologically first. Yeah. And we're going back to the 13th century, the reign of Henry III, who's the son of King John, father of Edward I. And we're going to 1252, which is the year in which Henry III was given by Hakon the Young, who was the King of Norway, a gift. And that gift was a polar bear. So this polar bear had come because Hakon the Young, as a Norwegian, had trade links with Iceland and Iceland had links with Greenland. And so there were polar bears that were able to be sourced. And obviously a very classy gift because not many kings in medieval Europe had a polar bear. So this polar bear was kept in the Tower of London. It had to wear a kind of a collar and a chain to stop it from running off.
对，因为按时间顺序我的最早。对。我们要回到13世纪，亨利三世统治时期，他是约翰王之子，爱德华一世之父。我们要回到1252年，正是在这一年，挪威国王哈康青年赠予了亨利三世一件礼物。这件礼物就是一头北极熊。这头北极熊的到来是因为哈康青年作为挪威人，与冰岛有贸易往来，而冰岛又与格陵兰岛有联系。因此，能够找到北极熊的来源。显然，这是一份相当高档的礼物，因为当时中世纪欧洲的国王中没几个人拥有北极熊。于是，这头北极熊被养在伦敦塔里。为了防止它逃跑，它必须戴着一种项圈和铁链。
But its keepers would very kindly allow it to swim in the Thames and hunt fish. So it would jump into the Thames and have it around. But it's unseasonably warm for a polar bear. Yeah, I think the temperatures were quite a bit colder then, weren't they? I mean, they had kind of
但它的饲养员非常友善地允许它在泰晤士河里游泳和捕鱼。所以它会跳进泰晤士河里扑腾。不过，对一头北极熊来说，这天气反常得有点暖和。对，我觉得那时的气温好像要冷得多，对吧？我的意思是，他们那种
chilly winters and things. I suppose so. Because it's actually it's it's uh the the start of a kind of ice age period mini ice age um that will finish off the viking settlements in greenland it's starting to happen at this point so yes so perhaps the polar bear was all right i mean i agree i don't think it was great um and the polar bear was not alone so this is part this, this is essentially, this is about animals that were kept in the Tower of London. So the Tower of London was the closest thing
寒冬之类的。我想是的。因为这实际上是……是某种冰河时期、小冰河时期的开始，呃，这将最终结束维京人在格陵兰岛的定居点，此时正开始发生。所以，是的，也许这头北极熊还过得去。我是说，我同意，我并不觉得它过得有多好，呃，而且这头北极熊并不孤单——所以这部分，本质上讲，这是关于养在伦敦塔里的动物。因此，伦敦塔是伦敦最接近动物园的地方。
that London had to a zoo. Because it's famous as Menagerie, isn't it? Is this when the Menagerie is founded? No. So the first, it begins in 1235 when Frederick II, you know, remarkable emperor, Stupor Mundi, one of the kind of the most charismatic and remarkable figures of medieval history, would well merit an episode. His sister, Eleanor of Provence, is marrying Henry III. And so what do you give?
因为它作为动物园（Menagerie）很有名，不是吗？动物园就是在这个时候建立的吗？不是的。所以最早的开始是在1235年，腓特烈二世，你知道的，那位了不起的皇帝，世界惊奇（Stupor Mundi），中世纪历史上最具个人魅力和非凡色彩的人物之一，完全值得单独做一期节目。他的妹妹埃莉诺·普罗旺斯正要嫁给亨利三世。那么你送什么呢？
What do you give the King of England? You give him three lions oh three lines on the shirt um well actually actually they're leopards they're leopards are they already a symbol of of england at this point they are right this is why he gives them um so they're either leopards or lions they're probably lions but there's some confusion um so these these lions are kept in the Tower of London. And then you get the polar bear. So that gets added. And then in 1255, so that's three years after the polar bear has arrived, Louis IX of France sends Henry III an elephant. An elephant? And the elephant has
你送英国国王什么礼物？你送他三头狮子——哦，球衣上的三头狮子——呃，实际上，实际上它们是豹子。它们是豹子吗？它们在这个时候已经是英格兰的象征了吗？是的，这就是为什么他送这个。所以它们要么是豹子，要么是狮子，很可能是狮子，但其中有些混淆。所以这些狮子被养在伦敦塔里。接着你又有了北极熊。所以这就加进去了。然后到了1255年，也就是北极熊到达三年后，法国的法兰西国王路易九世向亨利三世送了一头大象。一头大象？这头大象有
its own house. So that's nice. But what's not so nice for the elephant is that scholars in Henry III's court think that elephants don't drink water. So they... Why would they think such a stupid thing? They just give it wine. So the poor elephant is permanently drunk. A drunken elephant. God, trumpeting, no doubt, at all hours. Yeah.
它自己的房子。这挺好的。但对大象来说不太妙的是，亨利三世宫廷的学者们认为大象不喝水。所以他们……他们怎么会想出这么愚蠢的事情？他们只给它喂酒。所以这头可怜的大象一直处于醉酒状态。一头醉醺醺的大象。天哪，毫无疑问，整夜都在发出呼噜声。对。
So it's very badly behaved and doesn't live very long. No surprise there. So where's the King of France got the elephant from? I'm not sure. I would guess from India, so from the caliphate. Yeah. Because you remember that Harun al-Rashid, the great Abbasid caliph, gives an elephant to Charlemagne.
所以它表现很差，也没有活多久。这倒一点也不奇怪。那么法兰西国王是从哪里弄来这头大象的呢？我不确定。我猜是从印度，也就是从哈里发国。对。因为你记得伟大的阿拔斯王朝哈里发哈伦·拉希德曾向查理曼大帝赠送过一头大象。
So that must have come via India. So there must be an elephant well established, yeah. But this is the first elephant to arrive in England since the time of the Romans. Hold on. Since the time of the Romans? Do we know the Romans had elephants? Well, it's claimed that Caesar brought an elephant. Why would he bother? Why would he bother? Why would he bother? So that's perhaps not entirely.
所以那一定是通过印度运来的。因此当时一定有一条成熟的大象路线，对吧。但这却是自罗马时代以来第一头到达英格兰的大象。等等。自罗马时代以来？我们知道罗马人有大象吗？嗯，有人称凯撒带来过一头大象。他费那劲干嘛？他费那劲干嘛？他费那劲干嘛？所以这或许并非完全属实。
And it seems that Claudius rode into Colchester on an elephant. So they brought one over to impress the locals. That seems just immensely implausible to me. Don't you think? No, I like to think that that's what happened. Okay. You debunk when it suits you. And then when it doesn't suit you, you...
而且似乎克劳狄乌斯是骑着大象进入科尔切斯特的。所以他们带了一头过来是为了震慑当地人。这在我看来简直是不可思议。你不觉得吗？不，我愿意相信事情就是这样发生的。好吧。对你有利时你就去揭穿，对你不利时你就……
The Romans definitely had access to elephants. Yeah. You know, I'm sure at some point there were elephants. I don't believe anybody has ever ridden into Colchester on an elephant. Well, you and your scepticism. But this establishes the idea that a king should probably have animals, wild animals, exotic animals. And Edward I, who is henry iii's son he basically creates
罗马人确实有机会接触到大象。对。你知道的，我确信在某个时期确实有过大象。我不相信曾经有人骑着大象进过科尔切斯特。好吧，你和你的怀疑精神。但这确立了这样一种观念：国王大概应该拥有动物，野生动物，珍奇动物。而亨利三世的儿子爱德华一世，他基本上为这个动物园创建了
kind of permanent facilities for this menagerie um and it's a a tower that is now demolished that was just beyond the drawbridge uh and because it had lions it was called the lion tower um and this tradition of keeping animals there lasted throughout the middle ages through the tudor period um into the stewart period so um james the first is very keen on it so when he comes down from scotland he loves the fact that he owns basically owns a menagerie so he improves it he referred and james the first refurbishes um the the setting so that people can actually come and watch the lions prowl around and drink and eat and things like that. So it's a bit like a zoo. That's a zoo.
某种永久性的设施，呃，这是一座现已被拆除的塔楼，就位于吊桥外方；因为它曾关过狮子，所以被称为“狮子塔”。而这种在那里饲养动物的传统贯穿了整个中世纪、都铎时期，一直延续到斯图亚特时期。所以，詹姆斯一世对此非常热衷。因此，当他从苏格兰南下时，他非常喜欢自己基本上拥有一个动物园的事实。所以他进行了改善。他参考并翻新了环境，好让人们真正可以来看狮子四处踱步、饮水、进食诸如此类的事情。所以这有点像个动物园。这就是个动物园。
Yeah, it's starting to turn into a zoo. And so there are lions there, there are leopards, there are eagles, there are pumas, there's a tiger, and there's a jackal. So James loves everything that London offers, all the kind of stuff that he hadn't been able to get in Scotland. And absolutely, a menagerie is part of it. But no more polar bears, Tom. No more polar bears. And so this menagerie lasts through the, into the 18th century, but it's starting to become a bit kind of scuffy.
对，它开始变成一个动物园了。所以那里有狮子、豹子、老鹰、美洲狮、一只老虎和一只豺。所以詹姆斯喜爱伦敦提供的一切，所有他在苏格兰无法获得的东西。毫无疑问，动物园就是其中一部分。但没有更多的北极熊了，汤姆。没有更多的北极熊了。所以这个动物园一直持续到18世纪，但它开始变得有点破败了。
And into the 19th century, 1824, the RSPCA is founded, well before you get any charities devoted to ending cruelty to children, for instance. Well, I mean, the British famously care more about dogs than humans. So much more concerned with animals. And in 1826, do you know who is constable of the Tower of London? Is it Duke of Wellington? It is the Duke of Wellington.
进入19世纪，1824年，皇家防止虐待动物协会（RSPCA）成立了，这远早于任何致力于终止虐待儿童等行为的慈善机构出现。嗯，我的意思是，英国人出了名地比关爱人类更关爱狗。对动物要关心得多。而在1826年，你知道谁是伦敦塔的总管吗？是威灵顿公国吗？是威灵顿公爵。
How did you know that? I've just been secretly reading up on it. Oh, Dominic, that's cheating. That's cheating. So he basically decides that, you know, Tower of London is not a place for animals. That's odd for the Duke of Wellington because he's so
你怎么知道的？我刚才偷偷在读这方面的资料。哦，多米尼克，这算作弊。这算作弊。所以他基本上认为，你知道的，伦敦塔不是关动物的地方。这对于威灵顿公爵来说有点奇怪，因为他那么
reactionary. Well, on this occasion, he is looking to the future and so he sends it off to the newly built Regent's Park. So they've been built this great park at the end of regent street um built by the prince regent uh and this is a much better place for the duke wellington decides for animals and so 150 of them get sent there and then in 1828 and a zoo opens a london zoo opens in regent's park yeah And seven years later, the menagerie gets closed for good. So all the animals are cleared out of the Tower of London and it stops.
顽固保守。嗯，这一次，他放眼未来，于是把它送到了新建的摄政公园。所以他们建了这个巨大的公园，在摄政街的尽头，由摄政王修建的。威灵顿公爵认为，这里对动物来说是个更好的地方，于是150只动物被送到了那里。然后在1828年，一家动物园在摄政公园开业了——伦敦动物园在摄政公园开业了。七年后，动物园彻底关闭。因此，所有的动物都被清出了伦敦塔，这种历史结束了。
You know, that's the end. It's very sad. So that's the history of the menagerie in the Tower of London. But there's one intriguing further detail. So we have one of the themes of this week has been ghosts. Yeah. So we mentioned the cock lane ghost, the ghosts, the ghost of Priory here in St. Bethlehem.
你知道，这就结束了。真是令人难过。这就是伦敦塔内动物园的历史。但还有一个耐人寻味的小细节。我们本周的主题之一一直是鬼魂。对。所以我们提到了科克巷鬼魂、伯利恒修道院的鬼魂。
Lots of ghosts. The ghost of Skiffle. Yes, the ghost of Skiffle. But in 1816, a century, so I assume it was, would it be a beef eater? A guard in the Tower of London? I guess it might be, yeah eater, a guard of the Tower of London. I guess it might be. Anyway, he is standing by where the crown jewels kept. And suddenly he sees looming from out of the door that leads into the into the jewel room.
各种鬼魂。斯基夫尔的鬼魂。是的，斯基夫尔的鬼魂。但在1816年，又过了一个世纪，所以我猜那会是……会是一个皇家卫士吗？伦敦塔的守卫？我猜可能是的，卫士，伦敦塔的守卫。我猜可能是的。不管怎样，他正站在存放王冠珠宝的地方附近。突然，他看到一个巨大的身影从通往珠宝室的门里隐现出来。
He sees the figure of an enormous bear, an enormous bear. And so he raises his bayonet to try and stop it. And the bear just goes straight through the bayonet, through him and vanishes. And the guard, the beef eater collapses, comes to, says what he's seen. Obviously they assume he's drunk.
他看到了一只巨大的熊的身影，一头巨大的熊。于是他举起刺刀试图阻止它。而那只熊径直穿过了刺刀，穿过了他的身体，然后消失了。那个卫士，那个皇家卫士瘫倒在地，醒来后讲述了他所看到的一切。显而易见，他们认为他是喝醉了。
So they fetch the doctor. So the doctor confirms that he wasn't drunk and the poor man dies shortly afterwards. A shock of terror. So what was this ghost? What was the ghost of the bear? Could it have been the polar bear perhaps? Maybe, who knows?
于是他们找来了医生。医生证实他没有喝醉，不久之后这个可怜的人就去世了。被恐惧吓死的。那么这个鬼魂是什么？这只熊的鬼魂是什么？难道真的是那头北极熊吗？也许吧，谁知道呢？
Or could it have been the ghost of a bear that had been given to George III by the Hudson Bay Company? And George III was very disappointed with this bear because he'd wanted clothes. You know, because the Hudson Bay Company produced amazing fur coats or something. Yeah, a nice fur coat or hat or something like that. So he's very disappointed. He got a bear that was called Old Martin and was very, very grumpy.
或者，它会不会是哈德逊湾公司赠予乔治三世的一头熊的鬼魂？乔治三世对这头熊非常失望，因为他本来想要的是衣服。（你知道的，因为哈德逊湾公司生产精美的毛皮大衣之类的东西。）是的，一件漂亮的毛皮大衣或帽子之类的。所以他非常失望。他得到了一头名叫“老马丁”的熊，而且这头熊非常、非常暴躁。
So that was kept in the Tower of London. So maybe it was the ghost of Old Martin and was very, very grumpy. So that was kept in the Tower of London. So maybe it was the ghost of Old Martin. But it has been argued by London parapsychologists that perhaps this was the ghost of a bear that had lived in the Thames estuary way back when Britain was home to bears and other such wild animals. So lions and mammoths.
所以它被养在伦敦塔里。所以也许它是老马丁的鬼魂。但伦敦的超心理学家们认为，也许这是一头熊的鬼魂，这头熊早在不列颠还是熊和其他此类野生动物的家园时，就曾在泰晤士河口生活过。比如狮子和猛犸象。
You don't really tend to get prehistoric ghosts though, do you? I think that's the most implausible. Are you a leading London parapsychologist, don't you think? No, but I think. Your scepticism is out of control.
不过你通常不会真的碰到史前鬼魂，对吧？我认为那是最不可思议的。你难道不是伦敦顶尖的超心理学家吗？不，不过我觉得……你的怀疑精神已经失控了。
Reign it in. Yeah. You've scoffed at the idea that the Emperor Claudius rode an elephant into Colchester. I have, I've scoffed at the idea that the emperor claudius rode an elephant into colchester i have i have scoffed and now you're scoffing at the idea that the ghost scene in the tower of london might be the ghost of an ancient cave bear or something like that i think who knows dominic we don't know we don't know it's a mystery it sounds like it's the ghost of old martin that's my theory that's your that's what you're going for so sometimes in this podcast we like to address historical mysteries we've done the princes in the tower richard the third did it
收敛一点吧。你对克劳狄乌斯皇帝骑着大象进科尔切斯特的说法嗤之以鼻。我确实嗤之以鼻，我曾对克劳狄乌斯皇帝骑大象进科尔切斯特的说法嗤之以鼻，我嗤之以鼻。而现在你却对伦敦塔里出现的鬼魂可能是某种古代洞熊或其他什么东西的鬼魂嗤之以鼻。我想，谁知道呢，多米尼克，我们不知道，我们不知道，这是一个谜。听起来它就是老马丁的鬼魂，这就是我的理论。这就是你……这就是你的看法。所以有时候在这个播客里，我们喜欢探讨历史之谜，我们讲过塔中的王子，理查三世干的。
and i'm going to put my neck on the line again and say i think this is the ghost of old martin because the polar bear i don't see what motive the polar bear has well i think you're right i think you're right because also the the signal thing about a polar bear is that it's white and this is not mentioned yeah he would have said it was a ghost of a polar bear is that it's white. And this is not mentioned. Yeah, he would have said it was a ghost of a white bear. Unless, I suppose, the ghosts tend to be white anyway. No, only Scooby-Doo.
而我打算再次把头伸出去担保，我认为这就是老马丁的鬼魂，因为至于北极熊，我看不出北极熊有什么动机。嗯，我想你是对的，我想你是对的，因为关于北极熊最明显的特征是它是白色的，而这一点并没有被提及。对，他会说那是一只白熊的鬼魂。除非，我想，鬼魂本来就往往是白色的。不，只有史酷比。
I don't know if I... Do you know who would resolve this? Who? Dr. Johnson Ghost Hunter. Yes, he would. He would. Yeah, Amazon. So if anyone from Amazon is listening to this tv producers please do not ignore this brilliant idea right anyway so that's my that's my choice that's great so our next our next moment which we'll do after the break is much less tv well although there has been a tv program about it that's tantalizing okay we'll come back
我不知道我是不是……你知道谁能解开这个谜团吗？谁？约翰逊博士，捉鬼敢死队。是的，他会。他会的。对，亚马逊。所以如果亚马逊有任何人正在听这个节目，电视制作人们，请不要忽视这个绝妙的主意。好吧，总之，这就是我的选择。太棒了。那么我们的下一个时刻，我们将在休息之后进行，它跟电视没太大关系——不过虽然以前确实有过关于它的电视节目，真诱人。好吧，我们休息之后
after the break and find out what Dominic's got for you. We'll see you then. See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
回来，看看多米尼克给大家准备了什么。待会儿见。回头见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻，
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History.
评论，以及一抹娱乐圈八卦。而在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目以及提前获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。
The very last section of our London week. And today we are looking at events or episodes that have happened in the history of the British capital. We've had Henry III being given a polar bear in the first half. That was my choice. And now, Dominic, what's your choice? Well, Tom, we've had a lot in this week about people coming to London, about people moving to London, about people bringing bears to London or elephants or whatever they might be, baboons or lions or whatever. So I thought we'd end by people getting out of London. So you will no doubt know, as a top Londoner,
伦敦周的最后一个环节。今天我们来看看英国首都历史上发生过的事件或插曲。前半部分我们聊了亨利三世获赠一头北极熊。那是我的选择。现在，多米尼克，你的选择是什么？嗯，汤姆，这周我们讲了很多关于人们来到伦敦、搬到伦敦、把熊、大象或其他什么动物带到伦敦的故事，比如狒狒、狮子之类的一切。所以我决定以人们离开伦敦作为结尾。所以作为一个地道的伦敦人，你毫无疑问会知道，
what was the world's first underground railway. Do you know? I do, Metropolitan Line. It was the world's first underground railway? Do you know? I do, Metropolitan Line. It was the Metropolitan Line. So the Metropolitan Line opens in 1863, has gas-lit wooden carriages, and it's hauled by steam locomotives. And it's the setting for a Sherlock Holmes story, isn't it?
世界上第一条地下铁路是什么。你知道吗？我知道，大都会线。它真的是世界上第一条地下铁路线吗？你知道吗？我知道，大都会线。是大切。大都会线于1863年开通，拥有燃气照明的木制车厢，由蒸汽机车牵引。它也是福尔摩斯探案故事的背景，对吧？
It is, yeah, it is. And it's sort of very much redolent of that sort of Holmesian London, but also London, you know, the era just after the Great Exhibition, so London when it's the absolute sort of imperial capital. Yeah, it's the world's Babylon. Exactly. So the Metropolitan Railway, as it was then called, as you said, it goes from basically the city to Baker Street, Paddington.
是的，确实是的。它在很大程度上带有那种福尔摩斯式的伦敦色彩，同时也带有伦敦的印记，你知道的，也就是那段大博览会之后的时代，当时的伦敦是绝对意义上的帝国首都。对，它是世界的巴比伦。完全正确。所以大都会铁路，正如当时所称的，正如你所说，它基本上从伦敦市中心延伸到贝克街、帕丁顿。
But then they start extending it very quickly. So by 1864, it has reached Hammersmith in West London. By 1877, it has reached Richmond. And then the line starts to go out north into the sort of countryside of what's then Middlesex. So it goes to Harrow in 1880, Winston Churchill's old school. And eventually it gets as far as a place called Verney Junction in Buckinghamshire. So at that point, what we now think of as part of the London tube system or part of the underground system it extends more than 50 miles out of London
但随后他们开始非常迅速地延长线路。到1864年，它已经到达了西伦敦的哈默史密斯。到1877年，它到达了里士满。接着这条路线开始向北延伸到当时属于米德尔塞克斯郡的乡村地带。因此它在1880年到达了哈罗——温斯顿·丘吉尔的老学校。最终它甚至延伸到了白金汉郡一个叫弗尼交汇点的地方。所以到了那个时候，我们现在认为是伦敦地铁系统或地下系统一部分的路线，已经向西北延伸了超过50英里，一直深入到白金汉郡极其偏远的乡村。如果你看一下地图，特别是对那些来自海外、对伦敦公共交通系统极其熟悉的人来说，你会发现这条动脉从伦敦出发，向西北延伸到所谓的“内伦敦周边郡”（home counties）。所以这是那种富裕的、半乡村化的英格兰，英格兰南部。也就是米德尔塞克斯郡、赫特福德郡和白金汉郡。于是线路向外延伸。人们在那里打网球，还有股票经纪人，对吧？
to the northwest all the way into rural very rural Buckinghamshire so if you think about the map especially for people who are from overseas who are massively familiar with London's public transport system you have this artery going out of London, northwest into what are called the home counties. So this is sort of affluent, semi-rural England, southern England. So the counties of Middlesex, Hertfordshire, and Buckinghamshire. So the line goes out. People playing tennis, isn't it, and stockbrokers. Exactly.
好吧，我们马上会讲到他们是如何开始搞这一切的，因为大都会铁路不仅仅拥有铁路线周围的土地。它被允许——它成立时的立法允许它保留土地，购买并保留它认为以后可能会用到的土地。所以它基本上积累了远超实际需要的土地。这些土地沿着铁路线延伸，他们开始思考，好吧，既然这是一间私营公司，我们怎么才能把这笔资产利用起来——让所有这些土地为我们赚取丰厚的利润呢？显而易见的方法就是建设住宅。因此，随着铁路的发展，通勤现象也随之诞生——人们乘火车进城在伦敦工作，然后回到乡村。
Well, we'll come to how they start doing all that, because the Metropolitan Railway doesn't just have the land around the railway. It's been allowed. It's been its legislation setting it up has allowed it to keep land to buy and keep land that it thinks it may use later. So it's basically accumulated much more land than it than it needs. And that's running along this railway and they start to think well how can we make this because it's a private company how can we you know basically get this get all this land to turn us a pretty profit and the obvious way is to build housing so with the development of the railways you have the development of commuting so people are coming into town on the railway and working in london then going back out to the countryside.
你认为这是世界上第一次发生这种事吗？这又是伦敦的又一个第一吗？我想大概是的，汤姆，因为除了这里，你还在哪里能——我的意思是，我想在差不多同一时期，你可能会看到人们通勤去巴黎。巴黎，也许还有纽约。对，或者也许通勤去主要的——是的，纽约或德国的主要
Is this the first time it's happened in the world, do you think, something like this? Is this another London first? I think it probably is, Tom, because where else will you have – I mean, I suppose at roughly the same period you would have had people commuting into Paris. Paris and maybe New York. Yeah, or maybe commuting into major yeah New York or major
城市，所以通过所有这些，你会感觉到这是一件新鲜事。是的，它绝对是新鲜事。而大都会铁路的推动，既是由需求驱动的，也是由供给驱动的。大都会铁路的董事们，他们绝对想要——他们拥有这些保留下来的土地，他们希望有人住在上面，他们想在上面建房子，让人住在那里并乘坐他们的铁路，这样他们基本上就能赚大钱。于是他们成立了一家公司来启动他们所谓的
cities in Germany so you get the sense with all this that it is something new yeah it is absolutely it is new and the metropolitan it's driven it's both driven by demand but also by supply so the metropolitan um railway kind of directors they absolutely absolutely want to, they have this land, which they've held on to, and they want people to live in it, they want to build houses on it, people to live there and to take their railway, and they will basically make loads of money. So they set up a company to start what they call
“剩余土地委员会”，开始建造庄园、住宅区——也就是建造晚期维多利亚时代、爱德华时代的住宅区。第一个建在伦敦西北部的平纳（Pinner），时间是1900年。经营大都会线的人们一直在考虑如何招揽顾客。所以他们想要做的是，让人们使用他们的铁路——不仅是吸引人们来到伦敦，他们还想让人们使用铁路离开伦敦。
their Surplus Lands Committee to start building estates, housing estates, so late building estates housing estates so late victorian edwardian housing estates so the first one is built in pinna in sort of northwest london in 1900 and the people who are running the line the metropolitan line are thinking all the time about how to encourage custom so what they want to do is they want to get people to use their railway so not just people coming into london but they want to get people to use their railway. So not just people coming into London, but people in London to use their railway to go out of London.
他们想向人们推销铁路两旁的区域，推销那里的美景和好处，这样人们就会在那里买房。然后他们一辈子都会离不开这条铁路。太妙了。于是他们开始制作。他们有自己的——我的意思是，这在当时对一条铁路公司来说似乎是一件奇怪的事——对铁路公司来说绝对显得很奇怪的事，他们有自己的宣传部门，制作宣传册和海报，
And they want to kind of sell them the area on either side of the railway to sell the beauty of it and the benefits of it so that they will buy houses there. And then they'll be dependent on their railway for the rest of their lives. Yeah, brilliant. So they start producing. They have their own. I mean, it seems a weird thing for a – I a i mean certainly would have seemed a weird thing at the time for a railway line to do they have their own publicity department that produce leaflets and posters
特别是在大约——我想大约是1908年左右，爱德华时代前后的某个时期——他们制作了一本小册子、一本指南，也就是他们所谓的“延伸线指南”。这本指南基本上就是一本旅行手册。它告诉你去哪里住。这家酒吧有一款美味的馅饼。这里有一条美丽的散步小径，还有一些漂亮的树林。在切舍姆（Chesham）或阿默舍姆（Amersham）或任何这类地方下车。四处逛逛。
and particularly from about i think it's 1908 or so something around about that anyway in wardian period they produce a booklet a guide the guide to the extension line, as they call it. And that guide is basically a guidebook. It tells you where to stay. This pub does a lovely pie. There's a lovely walk here, some nice woods. Get off at Chesham or whatever or Amersham or any of these sort of places. Have a stroll around.
不是很美吗？也许你可以买栋房子。是的。这显然会大受欢迎，因为它契合了爱德华时代的某种时代精神，那个时代郊区急剧扩张，人们越来越富有，中产阶级日益富裕等等，但同时也伴随着对乡村以及这种正在消逝的……这种感觉就像是 Merchant Ivory（默昌特·伊沃里）电影里的世界。某种程度上，是的，我想是的。薄荷糖、麦秆帽、白亚麻西装。嗯，这基本上就是他们向你兜售的梦想，
Isn't it lovely? And maybe you could buy a house. Yes. And it's obviously going to be a hit because it taps into the sort of zeitgeist of the Edwardian era, which is a huge growth of suburbs, growth of people becoming richer and richer,
你会拥有属于自己的微缩版那种生活。而我真正想关注的时刻是在1915年，因为由于战争有所耽搁，但在1915年他们重新命名了他们的指南。它原本叫《延伸线指南》，而他们将其改名为《大都会领地指南》（Guide to Metroland）。“Metroland”（大都会领地）这个词是在1915年被创造出来的，它立刻变得——这其中有趣的地方在于，
more affluent, middle classes and so on, but also this fascination with the countryside and with this sort of vanishing. And this is kind of Merchant Ivory film land. Sort of, yes, I suppose so. Yeah. Pellets, warts, white linen suits. Well, that's the sort of the dream that they're selling you, basically,
它不仅仅指代伦敦西北部通往周边郡的那个地区，而且彻底成为了某种文化氛围、政治和经济氛围的代名词。所以《大都会领地》指南（你可以弄到它们，或者在网上找到它们的片段），它们向你兜售的是大自然的乐趣和所有迷人的树林。
that you'll have your own little version of that. And the real moment that I want to sort of focus on is in 1915, because it's been delayed because of the war, but in 1915 they renamed their guidebook. So it was the guide to the extension line, and they call it the guide to Metroland. And that term, Metroland, is coined in 1915, and it immediately becomes – the thing that's interesting about it
你知道，它在某个地方说——奇尔特恩丘陵是其中的一部分。所以它在某个地方说：“Metroland的每一位爱好者都可以拥有自己最喜欢的树林，山毛榉和杂木林，春天里一片颤动的嫩绿与可爱，十月里则是一片赤红与金黄。”这显然是针对伦敦人的。出来吧，你会有自己最喜欢的树林，坐上火车——他们甚至有带烟雾的火车。绝对的，所有这一切……
is it doesn't just refer to thing that's interesting about it is it doesn't just refer to that area running into the home counties out to the northwest of London, but it becomes absolutely redolent of a cultural kind of atmosphere and a sort of political and economic atmosphere. So the Metroland guidebook, and you can get them, or you can find bits of them online, they're selling you the joys of nature and all the lovely woods.
而他们兜售给你的正是这种世外桃源。在某种程度上，这与你在《柳林风声》中、或者在爱德华·托马斯的诗歌等作品中看到的世外桃源是同一种——比如那首《阿德尔斯特罗普》（Adlestrop），诗中他下了火车，或者他在格洛斯特郡的火车上，看到鸟儿歌唱等等。这就是托尔金在同一时期创作《霍比特人》、后来又创作《指环王》时所呈现的那种世外桃源。这种理想化的、被……一种逃离工业革命的渴望所吞噬的英国乡村。
You know, it sort of says at one point, sort of the Chiltern Hills are part of it. So it says at one point, each lover of Metroland may have his own favourite wood, beech and coppice, all tremulous, green loveless in spring and russet and gold in October. So this is obviously aimed at Londoners. Come out, you'll have your own favourite wood, you get get the train they have a train on smog exactly all of this all of this
没错，由城市居民创造。由工业革命所促成。正是如此。完全是这样。所以从某种奇怪的角度来说，你可以说这是一种由迪士尼风格打造的英国乡村。但他们同时也想卖房子。
and what they're selling you is this kind of arcadia so it's the same arcadia in some ways that you see in the wind and the willows that you see in i don't know the poetry of edward thomas or something at this poem adelstrop in which which, of course, he gets off the train, or he's on the train in Gloucestershire, and he sees the birds singing and all that stuff. It's the Arcadia that you get the same period Tolkien is writing, The Hobbit, and then later The Lord of the Rings. This sort of idealized rural England that is consumed by... A kind of escape from the Industrial Revolution.
因此，小册子刚一推出，他们就开始行动了……他们开始购买更多土地。他们开始在那些对许多了解伦敦或英国的听众来说听起来极其平淡无奇的地方买地。比如温布利、里克曼斯沃斯、尤其是尼斯登（Neasden）。尼斯登成了这种现象的伟大象征。
Exactly, by urban people. Made possible by the Industrial Revolution. Exactly, by urban people. Made possible by the Industrial Revolution. Exactly that. Exactly that. So in a weird way, you could say it was kind of Disneyland rural England that is being created. But they also want to sell the houses.
一个笑话，对吧？所以这些地方之所以成为笑话，是因为它们被视为典型的高度平庸和市井。但如果你去那些地方，如果你搭乘大都会线，下车看看那些房子，你会看到大量建于20世纪20年代左右的、这种刻意复古的小屋风格的都铎贝瑟尼式建筑，它们作为“你自己的小小乡间别墅”、“你自己的小小乡村住宅”卖给人们。所以你有一个凸窗，有一个陡峭的屋顶，
So as soon as they produced the booklet, they really start... They start buying up more land. They buy it. Start in places that now, to a lot of our listeners who know London or who know England, will sound incredibly humdrum. So Wembley, Rickmansworth, Neasden in particular. Neasden becomes a great symbol of this.
所有这些。步行一小段路就能带你到一个美丽的公园。那里有一个高尔夫球场。在你去的那个地方的高街上，可能还建有一家20世纪20年代或30年代的装饰艺术风格电影院。所以这是一个充满雄心壮志的世界。它是郊区的。它是温文尔雅的。
Joke, doesn't it? So these things that are kind of a joke because they're seen as quintessentially kind of banal and suburban. But if you go to those places if you get the metropolitan line get off the houses lots of kind of tudor bethen houses so that they're built in let's say the 1920s in this deliberately retro kind of cottagey style and they are sold to people as this is your own little country villa this is your own little country house um so you've got a kind of bay window and you've got the steep roof
这些房子都被取名为诸如“月桂树”、“橡树”之类名字。而实际上它所变成的——“大都会领地”也成为了这种形象的代名词，这也是节目老朋友斯坦利·鲍德温的代名词，汤姆。这就是斯坦利·鲍德温的英国。也就是20世纪20、30年代的英国。因为鲍德温最著名的演讲，是他1924年发表的——那是大都会领地发展的巅峰——他说：“对我来说，英国就是乡村，乡村就是英国。当我问自己我所说的英国是什么意思，当我在国外时我想象的是什么英国，”然后他滔滔不绝……他脑海中想到的是英国的声音：乡村铁匠铺里铁锤敲击铁砧的叮当声、清晨露水中的秧鸡叫声、镰刀划过磨刀石的声音，以及 plough team（犁地队）越过山岗的景象。自英国成为一片土地以来，这景象就一直是英国。并且永远都是。
and all that sort of stuff. A short stroll will take you to the lovely park. There's a golf course. There may be an art deco cinema built in the 1920s or the 1930s on the high street at the place where you're going. So it's this sort of world of it's aspirational. It is suburban. It's sort of genteel.
对。但他却说，英国唯一的永恒景象是……问题在于，尽管他在20世纪20年代这么说，但这一切其实已经彻底消逝、不复存在了。但他这番话是对……我的意思是，他的受众、他的选民，正是那些住在那些房子里的人。对。也就是那些渴望向上流动的核心家庭，
The houses are all called things like the laurels or the oaks and things like that. And actually what it becomes, what Metroland also becomes relevant of, very much a friend of the show, Tom, Stanley Baldwin. This is Stanley Baldwin's Britain. So 1920s, 1930s Britain. Because Baldwin's single most famous speech is when he gave this 1924, so the peak of Metroland, he gives this speech saying, to me, England is the country,
他们在大都会铁路公司建造和提供的房地产上购买了新房子。这不正是伟大的住房热潮之一吗？这绝对是，而且可能有很多甚至正在收听这个播客的人，在没有多加思索的情况下，实际上就生活在斯坦利·鲍德温的英国里，他们生活在大都会领地里，生活在爱德华时代到第二次世界大战之间建造的房屋里。是的。所有那些郊区带状开发项目。
and the country is England. When I ask myself what I mean by England, what I think of England when I'm abroad, and he goes on, blah, blah, blah, what he thinks of is the sounds of England, the tinkle of the hammer on the anvil in the country smithy, the corn crake on a dewy morning, the sound of the scythe against the whetstone and the sight of a plough team coming over the brow of a hill. The sight that has been England since England was a land. And always will be.
战后，又迎来了贝杰曼（Betjeman）的时代。所以情况是这样的，汤姆，“Metroland”这个词非常迅速地在全国范围内广为人知。在伊夫林·沃的书里，有一个角色嫁给了大都会子爵。她成了大都会子爵夫人。这开始变成一个笑话了吗？你看，对于知识分子来说，这确实是个笑话。它一直都是一个笑话。
Yeah. But the one eternal sight of England, he says. And the thing is that even as he's saying this in the 1920s, it's utterly faded and it's gone. But he is saying it to, I mean, his audience, his electorate, are the people who live in those houses. Yeah. So nuclear families who are upwardly mobile,
给那些自命不凡的伦敦精英。自命不凡，没错。我想我们在之前的播客里提到过这一点。约翰·凯里的书《知识分子与大众》，讲的就是20世纪初知识分子对大众的群体转向，他们讨厌大众的一切——郊区、装饰艺术电影院、高尔夫球场，所有这些人们其实喜欢的东西，
who have bought new houses on the estates, basically built and provided by the metropolitan railway but this is one of the great housing booms isn't it it is absolutely and lots of people probably even listening to this podcast without really thinking about it are actually living in stanley baldwin's britain they're living in metroland they're living in 1920s or houses built between the edwardian period and the Second World War. Yeah. All those sort of suburban ribbon developments.
它们正是Metroland的象征，也是知识分子、作家、先锋派、弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫信徒等这类人所痛恨的一切的象征。因此，Metroland恰恰成为了这样一个靶子。好吧，我的意思是，平纳依然是一个……平纳，尼斯登。尼斯登是足球迷们脸色苍白的地方……
And then after the war, you have Betjeman's. So what happens, Tom, is that the phrase Metroland becomes very nationally known very quickly. So in Evelyn Waugh's books, there's a character who marries Viscount Metroland. She becomes Lady Metroland. Is it starting to become a joke then? Well, you see, it is a joke to intellectuals. And it's always a joke
罗恩·尼（Ron Knee），尼斯登镇的主教练。是的，在《私家侦探》（Private Eye）杂志里。所以那里的地方在某种程度上已经被稍微更低端的郊区所吞噬了。是的，某种程度上是这样。而平纳则是……平纳稍微温文尔雅一点，对吧？稍微温文尔雅一点，但如果你是T.S.艾略特的话，还是显得有点俗气。嗯，我觉得不能这么说，离伦敦越远，
to intellectuals. Sneery metropolitan types. Sneery, exactly. I think we've mentioned it before on this podcast. John Carey's book, The Intellectuals intellectuals and the masses which is all about the kind of intellectual turn against the masses at the beginning of the 20th century what all the things they dislike about the masses suburbs art deco cinemas the golf courses all of those things that actually people like um they are emblematic of Metroland and they're emblematic of everything
沿着大都会线走，它就会变得越温文尔雅。不过大都会线上的每一站，都是英国式势利的不同变体的避雷针。这么说公平吗？对，我想这大概挺公平的。你会因为不同的原因，
that intellectuals, writers, avant-gardists, Virginia Woolfists, people of that kind hate. And so Metroland does exactly that, become a bit of a sort of a punching ball. Well, I mean, Pinner is still a... Pinner, Neasden. Neasden is where football fans, Ashen-faced...
对不同的地区嗤之以鼻。阿默舍姆（Amersham）——我确信它绝对可爱而且位于奇尔特恩丘陵，但在许多人看来，它不过是英格兰中部那种极其无聊的地方，你知道的，诸如此类。我想你是完全对的，乔利伍德（Chorleywood）或者诸如此类的所有这些地方。但当然，有一个人作为知识分子，却超越时代地捍卫了这一点，
Ron Knee, the manager of Neaston Town. Yeah, in Private Eye. So that's kind of been swallowed up by slightly more low-rent suburbia. Yes, I suppose, to some extent. Whereas Pinner is... Pinner is slightly more genteel, isn't it? Slightly more genteel, but still a bit common, if you're T.S. Eliot. Well, I think it's not fair to say that the further you get out of London
正如你所说，那就是约翰·贝杰曼。有趣的是，贝杰曼并非来自大都会领地，他在海格特长大，但当这个地方真正消亡时他才开始写作——以至于到了20世纪30年代，他们停止使用这个短语，大都会铁路公司停止使用这个短语，这实际上向你展示了它变得有多么的——怎么说呢——去阶级化（déclassé），完全是这样。然后，从20世纪30年代中期开始，大都会铁路基本上就不复存在了。它被并入了伦敦交通局。对许多人来说，它似乎就像是某种……你知道的，他们把它忘了，忘了它曾经存在过。但贝杰曼很早就开始为这条线路以及沿线的地方写诗了。所以到1954年，他写了一首名为《米德尔塞克斯》的诗。我们读其中一节就好。对于不了解贝杰曼的人来说，这非常具有贝杰曼的风格：
along the Metropolitan Line, the more genteel it becomes. But every stop on the Metropolitan Line is a kind of lightning rod for different shades of British snobbery. Would that be fair? Yeah, I think that's probably fair. You kind of sneer at different regions
“红色的电车欢快地驶入赖斯利普的花园，带着千百张月票和通行证，一位女士优雅地下车，皱着眉头匆忙穿过混凝土车站，走向那些边缘地带，那里仅存的几处树篱，依然守护着我们失落的乐园——米德尔塞克斯的乡村风光。”所以贝杰曼对那种正在消逝的乡村风貌是有所体察的。但他并不对郊区嗤之以鼻。他虽然对它们带有一点苦涩的幽默，但同时也严肃对待它们。
for different reasons. Amersham, which I'm sure is absolutely lovely and in the Chilterns, to a lot of people would just seem Middle England, utterly boring, you know, sort of. I think you're absolutely right, Chorleywood or whatever, all these sort of places. But the one person, of course, who's, as it were, an intellectual who champions this ahead of his time,
然后在1973年，当贝杰曼已经成为某种……他已经成为了一个国家瑰宝，一个讨人喜欢的泰迪熊式环保主义诗人时，BBC请他拍一部关于大都会领地的纪录片，而他也照做了。所以你可以在网上看到这部电影。他在伦敦上了火车，手里拿着一本20世纪20年代的指南。他基本上就顺着这条线一直坐到了终点。我的意思是，他有一句非常精彩的话。
as you said, is John Betjeman. So the funny thing is that Betchamon isn't from metroland he grew up in highgate um but he's writing about it when it's really gone so that they stopped using the phrase the metropolitan railway stopped using the phrase in the 1930s that actually shows you how quickly it's become kind of i say yeah de classe exactly and then, from the mid-1930s onwards, the Metropolitan Railway basically ceases to exist. It's absorbed into London Transport. It sort of is just, to a lot of people,
他说：“Metroland是第一次世界大战的孩子，却被第二次世界大战所遗忘。”然后他就出发了。他从贝克街出发。如果你曾经在贝克街站下车，贝克街上方有一栋大型的新古典主义公寓楼，名叫奇尔特恩大厦（Chiltern Court）。所以他一开始就是从谈论这个开始的。
it just seems like a sort of, you know, they forget about it, they forget it ever happened. But Betjeman is writing poems about the line and about the places along the line quite early on. So in 1954, he has a poem called Middlesex. So just read one verse. Very Betjeman for people who don't know Betjeman. Gaily into riselip gardens runs the red electric train with a thousand tars and pardons daintily alights a lane, hurries down the concrete station with a frown of concentration out into the outskirts edges where a few surviving hedges
这感觉就像是，你知道的，他们把这事忘了，仿佛它从未发生过。但贝杰曼很早就开始为这条铁路线以及沿途的风景写诗了。所以在1954年，他写了一首名为《米德尔塞克斯》的诗。我读其中一节。对于不了解贝杰曼的人来说，这非常具有他的风格。红色电动列车欢快地驶入赖斯利p花园，带着一千个歉意与原谅，一位淑女优雅地下了车，带着专注的眉头匆匆走下混凝土车站，来到郊区边缘，那里有几处幸存的树篱
keep alive our lost Elysium, rural Middlesex again. So Betjeman is kind of alive to the vanishing rural nature of it. But he doesn't sneer at the suburbs. He's sort of, he's wry about them, but he sort of takes them seriously at the same time and then in 1973 when betcherman has become a bit of a he's become a national treasure so he's this sort of cuddly teddy bear conservationist poet laureate the bbc asked him to make a film about metroland um which he does so you can see the film online. He gets on the train in London with a guidebook from the 1920s. And he basically just takes the line all the way to the end. I mean, he has this fantastic line.
守护着我们失去的极乐净土，也就是乡村风光的米德尔塞克斯。所以贝杰曼对这里正在消失的乡村特质是有所察觉的。但他并没有嘲笑郊区。他对它们有点儿苦笑，但同时又很认真地看待它们，然后在1973年，当贝杰曼已经成为一个有点儿……他已经成了国宝级人物，他是那种人见人爱的泰迪熊式环保主义桂冠诗人，BBC邀请他拍一部关于大都会之乡的电影，他照做了，所以你可以在网上看到这部电影。他带着一本二十年代的旅游指南在伦敦上了火车。他基本上就是一直坐着这趟车到了终点。我的意思是，他有一句非常精彩的话。
He says, Metroland is a child of the First World War, forgotten by the second. And off he goes. He starts at Baker Street. If you ever got off at Baker Street Station, there's a big kind of neoclassical apartment block above Baker Street called Chiltern Court. So he starts by talking about that.
他说，大都会之乡是第一次世界大战的产物，却被第二次世界大战所遗忘。然后他就出发了。他从贝克街开始。如果你曾在贝克街车站下车，贝克街上方有一栋很大的新古典主义公寓楼，叫做奇尔特恩法院。所以他一开始就是从谈论那个地方开始的。
Then he goes to all these places, St. John's Wood, Neasden, Wembley, Harrow, Pinner, Chorleywood, Amersham. And he goes all the way. And it's this beautiful film, very 70s, very melancholy, kind of nostalgic. So it's funny watching it because you're watching multiple eras at once. You're watching somebody from the 70s talking about a sort of project from really the 1910s and 20s, but which was itself the product
然后他去了所有这些地方，圣约翰伍德、尼斯登、温布利、哈罗、平纳、乔利伍德、阿默舍姆。他一路前行。这是一部非常美丽的电影，充满70年代风格，非常忧郁，带着一种怀旧感。所以看这部电影很有趣，因为你同时在看好几个时代。你在看一个70年代的人在谈论一个实际上是1910年代和1920年代的项目，而这个项目本身又是建于1860年代的铁路线的产物。
of a line that was built in the 1860s. And also in the 70s, I mean, that's a period where a lot of Victorian and Edwardian architecture is being demolished. So most notoriously, the Euston Arch, which Benjamin was very upset about. Exactly. This great neoclassical structure outside the Euston railway station. And what's even better, Tom,
而且在70年代，我的意思是，那个时期许多维多利亚和爱德华时期的建筑都被拆除了。最臭名昭著的就是尤斯顿拱门，本杰明对此非常难过。确实如此。尤斯顿火车站外这座宏伟的新古典主义建筑。汤姆，更棒的是，
is that that documentary, Metroland, goes out on the BBC, and I think it's February 1973. And I think I'm right in saying it goes out on the day that it goes out. There's been a rail strike. It's just perfect timing. So he goes all the way along the line. And this is the perfect point for it to end. He goes to Verney Junction in rural Buckinghamshire,
那部纪录片《大都会》在BBC播出，我想大约是1973年2月。如果我没记错的话，它就在播出的当天遭遇了铁路罢工。这时间配合得太完美了。于是他沿着整条线路一直走。这正是它结束的完美地点。他来到了白金汉郡乡村的弗尼尤地带，
which by then has closed. And he goes, and there's nothing there. And the final line of the whole film, he says, Grass triumphs, and I must say i'm rather glad and that's the brilliant so um that's the perfect notion which to end a series about london so i hope you've enjoyed our our london week um thanks very much bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access,
那时已经关闭了。他走过去，那里空无一物。整部电影的最后一句话，他说，草取得了胜利，我必须说我倒挺高兴。这真是太棒了，所以，嗯，这是结束伦敦系列节目的绝佳理念，所以希望大家喜欢我们的伦敦周，非常感谢，再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、
ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's rest launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。